girls that you all know this but
Mother's Day is coming up this weekend
and we love our mom we want to treat her
with flowers and tasty desserts right so
I'm joined by Manana R Kelly and the
owner of Manon Bakery with what you're
cooking up for Mother's Day you guys
have some incredible things you recently
expanded yes we did so when I used to go
in now I should we should tell people
it's off Flamingo and rainbow rainbow
um and it was this beautiful shop with
these amazing amazing pastries but now
it's everything yes what did you guys do
how did you expand what do you offer now
so we offer literally everything I like
to mention as like a One-Stop shop so we
have a flower Boutique connected to the
bakery which is like just to the side
which we have so many beautiful
different Arrangements yeah so this is
like gorgeous it's like a purse
yeah it's like a flower purse so this
has made a lot of grass oh my goodness
all the flowers right there and now we
do catering we have event rooms we do
breakfast everything there's a sit-down
section before it was just you walk can
you grab and you go and you go and now
you can grab and enjoy it's huge I mean
we offer everything but well let's look
at all about that yeah I was going to
say so for Mom you you need to get the
order in probably pretty soon let's
start with flowers
um it's Monday folks it's on Sunday so
it's not too late no it's not okay you
know maybe you're walking in maybe you
don't know what color mom likes or what
kind of flowers what do you suggest for
those folks who want to come in and buy
flowers but they don't know where to
start yes colorful well also another
thing I'd like to mention we always have
the arrangements like prepared so
there's some flowers that you can get or
some already
um like cakes that are available so
everything's already done okay so you
don't have to stress out too much we are
we already have like last minute things
for the people that are laughing tonight
I love this idea okay and then once you
get the flowers home is there a way to
keep them how do you keep them last
lasting longer okay if you are going to
be making them at home my number one tip
is when you're cutting the stem cut it
at a diagonal okay not straight got it
it makes the water shoot up to the
flower cooker and it keeps it hydrated
excellent second one is just keep
refreshing the water and keep it next to
sunlight it's like the most like it's
basically you gotta remember to do it
now remember this is the bread and
butter quite literally this is where you
guys started as I open this up to just
kind of show off some of the amazing
things that are in here
um tell me about what what you have what
do we have here so this is our box with
flowers and pastry so it'll be a dozen
pastries right here we put a few in the
front so you guys can get a big a better
peek at it so a dozen pastries a dozen
pastries beautiful flowers your choice
of flowers which we picked roses because
everyone loves roses so this is
something that you guys offer yes this
is something that we offer oh my
goodness now really quick before we run
out of time run me through what we have
oh my gosh these are actually all my
favorites kiss cake is my favorite
raspberry with meringue vanilla oh my
God chocolate eclair everyone loves
lemon bars we also have apple bars fruit
tarts coconut cake cannolis I have to
say our cannolis are the best so you
guys I've had I think all of these
including the creme relay and I said
that is my husband's hands down favorite
he said nothing compares to your
question it's like crunchy at the top
warm and then it's like so good I don't
even know how to do it see that is how
you sell it folks so you could buy these
individual and then um full-size cakes
like you mentioned flowers that are
already ready to go
um Flamingo and rainbow okay thank you
so much this morning go check them out
this is just a really incredible yummy
place to visit Cherry if you haven't
been you gotta go oh man I gotta go oh
you got to bring back some of those
sweets Heather those look so good